this is like a shirt from eighth grade
I'm not feeling confident Holly it's
great it was like 20 years ago my hands
are getting a little sweaty thinking
about it what do have the most to lose
oh I'm studying to be a teacher my
favorite part rain my name I'm coloring
this characters overalls first which of
the following is an irrational number I
didn't know numbers were irrational it's
not 4.5 102 that's look that's a number
does anyone know what a rational number
is I'm gonna go with B I don't even know
what to call the check mark symbol I'm
gonna say that that makes no sense to me
so I hope it's the irrational one oh boy
algebra solve the system of two
equations oh Christ on a crutch okay
this I kind of remember doing and kind
of enjoying it's like a puzzle
I like these ones I'm good okay so - why
equals 4 I'm gonna go with X being a
small number I I have no idea what I'm
doing I changed my mind X is a big
number 15 times 4 is 60
he goes to X minus 4 64 is to X so x
equals 32 yeah B how much time will an
old car take to cover a distance of 39
miles at a speed of 13 miles per hour
why are you driving 13 miles now or what
is wrong with your car Express distance
as a function of time so I'm circling B
and I'm getting a little concerned
because I think B has been my answer for
the last like four or five answers time
is pretty sure the answer is the speed
of light 39 divided by 13 which is 313 x
equals y a boat starts from a port and
moves 12 miles north and then moves five
miles east what is the present distance
of the boat from the port so there's a
triangle involved and I call a friend
all right this is that classic a squared
plus B squared equals C squared I have
to find the hypotenuse so we're just
gonna guess on this one 12 times so
let's take the square root of 169 I
believe that is liq to what volume of
ice creams contain in a 10 centimeter
high ice-cream cone with a base radius
of 4 I don't remember the volume of a
cone
this is asking me
okay so this is like V equals 1/2 of B
and H or something like that I think
it's time for a B can you go number it
number a I felt good about it but C
study kids say stay in school don't be
like don't be like unki Chris who is
this guy what's his name can we give him
a name
you